[Music]
in scammed the scammer news oh I love
these submitted by its October
halloweeners a student tricked a scammer
into giving him money right about the
bat [ __ ] this is my favorite [ __ ] the
Nigerian prince gave money to the
student finally his name is I don't
forget to subscribe
nice speaking of friends friends look
for you to be our friend and so try
thank you yes yeah if you haven't
subscribed already what are you waiting
for
hey maybe you can be our Chandler Joey
okay you go
armonica our alley cat you won't be our
alley cat it's smelly cat smelly cat
smelly
naked guy across the bed are they
feeding ya or be Ursula wait what Ursula
Ursula Stevie's twin sister do you not
watch read there's a villain in Mert a
Little Mermaid I don't [ __ ] know well
we're talking about frog I got nieces
and nephews now man we're I mean cartoon
land what are you gonna be a daddy
though tell me about it subscribe now so
Steve could be a daddy
becoming a father last night
it takes one night that's what I heard I
told you I'm not smart anyway this
student here his name is Ross he's 22
years old he's a student at the
University of Limerick he says that he
wants to waste online scammers time so
they're not wasting anyone else's time
and so when he receives money from these
scammers he gives it to charity
that's dope he actually gets Mikey yeah
yes these are some bad scammers there's
this one scammer um this guy actually
hacks their computer and it deletes a
[ __ ] they freak them out it is so [ __ ]
part of it I think you sent me that one
yeah yeah but I just go down the rabbit
hole with these guys in and like you're
deleting all my [ __ ] [ __ ] you
is this before or after you watch
[ __ ] goats and pyjamas it's goats
eating pajamas it's bananas in pajamas
and pajamas would be funny as [ __ ] it
would be I went through a binge of
watching corgis being pet you see upside
down I told you you should see them jump
Courtney's jumping is I love that I have
that anyway this is Ross
that's not the Ross I know interesting
looking Japanese guy thinking this way
I've never seen a Geisha that that
looked like that before
he's what procreating Japanese no he was
the Limerick our University that sounds
made up
yeah it's unreal this I think is you
know limit quite young phrase anyway so
[ __ ] I pressed print
you're gonna put out that photo the
wonder if we're related anyway this is
the email that he received titled
business opportunity by song and Wendy
hello friend didn't even try to be white
or something you know they always
pretend like is a new tactics a new
tactic hello my name is Richard Johnson
and it's like an Indian on other life oh
really
I'm from Indiana he's from Ireland cuz
I'm like I think it's early but I wanna
be wrong so I googled it anyway so the
email says hello friend pleased to be
with you I know this email will come to
a surprise to you but permit me to
desire to go into business with you my
name is Sullivan and I'm a big business
banker looking I'm big business baker
big one that small be ok looking to go
into business with fellow enthusiastic
businessman sorry I want you to invest
one thousand pounds into I mean in my
company for exchange for half business
my business is all about trading stocks
last week I made a small sum of thirty
five thousand pounds you may wonder why
I need one thousand pounds yes
I have 35,000 pounds yes I want to teach
young businesspeople my knowledge which
comes at a fair price if you send me
PayPal transfer of 1,000 pounds we can
begin immediately and become rich kind
regards Solomon
how can anyone review such a [ __ ]
that's good that's when Ross replied he
said my dearest Solomon delighted to
receive your intriguing business
proposal as you know I'm a very
enthusiastic businessman and I think
1,000 pounds is an insult I have
attached proof of payments of 50,000
pounds to get the ball running one thing
you need to understand about doing
business in Europe is we do things big
please get back to me ASAP to discuss
our next move best Ross and he attached
so this is the email I just read yeah
and he attached this fake PayPal thing
is Solomon Gundy fifty thousand pounds
and then the guy solomon ends up saying
like oh you know like i haven't received
the money but then Ross says that PayPal
flagged it as possible scam so he so if
Solomon needs to send its Ross a small
amount so they can see that they have a
relationship so he ended up sending him
25 pounds so he ended up donating that
to cancer just dog that's a lot of it
whatever a country they're from like
that's 50 bucks yeah that'll probably
buy like eight cows and [ __ ]
well it's 50 bucks is the dollar really
that we well cuz it's not wrong it's 25
pounds right close to 40 or something
maybe 30 or 40 I don't know no I mean
who the [ __ ] cares about the conversion
the point is whatever the [ __ ] point
is it's good you could move past it the
point is in their country that's a lot
of [ __ ] money right thirty dollars
I had to convert it I needed to know I
couldn't move past it Joe yeah it's a
lot of money for Loomis then so he ended
up getting money from the scammer Ostara
Sullivan I want to give you some advice
one thing you need to understand
County final is never trust a short puck
and those key words because he and he
also had them speak in this different
terminology which is from the Gaelic
Athletic Association sport of hurling so
money would be code for high ball
transaction would be cold that's a more
easy short puck outs
business would be code for County final
and paypal would be code for the square
this guy's good so he's out here
collecting like 25 bucks every single
time or 30 bucks every single time he
goes through scammers and they're
actually paying him yeah because the
third time disease say how much he got
out of everyone no I just know about
this one but he does they could probably
do that to love like if it worked in one
type of scammers you know true I wish we
could forward all our scammers [ __ ] to
him and then he just deals with it do
you just have a full-time job scamming
the scammers yes smart do you think the
Prince of Nigeria is like man my [ __ ]
good name family son-of-a-bitch my
[ __ ] branding is terrible you can't
even buy [ __ ] like in public either like
your the Nigerian things
no no way pal and he's like I'll take
two elephants like yeah [ __ ] right
Prince of Nigeria yeah
fall for that word again Oh nuts so but
that'd be funny he's like I'll take two
elephants but first you need to send me
this he actually needed it the actual
prince needed it yeah I think I saw a
African gang like a mob in China like we
were at a club in Beijing and there was
a whole back row like three four tables
of just like these African guys like and
it looked like the movies like they have
very colorful wardrobes with the hats
and [ __ ] and they were just like a group
of like ladies like they're not like not
like all covered a Muslim style like it
was like it was like hot like it was
weird like a music video like yeah and
then do it like Chinese people with of
but they look like a straight-up like
African like mob like it was crazy
huh yeah like and they're just chilling
in the back like looking like scary is
she
just staring at everybody and like doing
like gangster [ __ ] you know do they have
those Aladdin swords no out of a [ __ ]
dope though I'm like what the [ __ ] is
shape stored like scimitar whatever the
quality yeah yeah but I was like I've
never ever seen this like what's going
on and out of all the places China in
the middle of [ __ ] China even in
Japan that I feel like there's a lot of
people from like Nigeria like African
people that go to work there because it
make more money you know there are and
there you speak good Japanese they can't
speak any English really good yeah and
they claim to be from New York or LA
yeah that's the funny [ __ ] because
you'll go to places like hara jakku or
whatever right and there'll be hip hop
stores and then they'll be like black
guys like like don't be speaking
japanese and they'll be like would you
like to come in we have all shoes and
sales on like it's all they're like
basically street hustling and trying to
get people into the sport it's really
heavy
Africanized african japanese yeah yeah
interesting when i was in mexico that
did that but they were offering tequila
a [ __ ] door and I took it and it was
bomb oh but they're African guys no no
there's like there's the guys that are
trying to get that's amazing that's
pretty phat this pretty dope
you slide about Street hustling because
I was related yeah they're street
hustling yeah particular at the door the
other Avenue honest conversation and
they claim that they're from LA New York
yeah they're trying to play an act it's
easier to sell like cuz it's like the he
knows blocking about your pop guy from
New York yeah it's like now you're they
can't speak English it's like yeah
you're like darker scheme here yes so
something about your outfit
and actually they would actually try to
like talk to you in English sometimes -
yeah yeah to be like ya know familiar
and sometimes they'd talk to me not
knowing that I speak English yeah and
you speak back to them in English and
they're like American English so we just
end up staring at each other like why
you what everyone's pretending to be
American yeah what are you mate I'm from
Japan
[Laughter]
[Music]